Good Morning John
I do not want to belittle the importance of
the case of the poopy Nintendo
But I think we also need to recognize that
there are bigger poops
being put into more important Nintendos all
accross the world right now
That we need to pay attention do.
Obviously, BP is putting poop into the gulf
of mexico's nintendo.
Isreal and Palestine have so much poop in
their Nintendos that no one even knows where
any of it came from.
But much closer to home for all of us on YouTube
Viacom is attempting to put poop in YouTube's
Nintendo
And this is a very big deal
So I invited YouTube and Viacom to com over
to my house
And sit down at my dining room table and talk
it out.
Unfortunately both of them ignored my request
and so I had to do it all by myself.
Hello YouTube
Hello Viacom
Your website is really nothing but illegally
uploaded copyrighted content,
and we want two very reasonable things from
you.
One, we would like compensation for the videos
that were viewed on your site
that were illegally uploaded.
And two, we want you to manually approve every
single video that gets put on your site.
OK, let's take the first point first,
because we might actually be able to do something
about that.
it might make sense for you to be compensated
for your content.
How much do you want for that.
We would like one billion dollars.
How about we give you two dollars per thousand
views
on all of the content that was uploaded illegally,
that's more than anyone else gets.
Uhh, how about ONE BILLION DOLLARS!!!
OK, well, let's table that for now.
But let's just be honest here,
the vast majority of clips on YouTube are
uploaded legitimately and legally
by the owners of the clips,
whether it's just some guy in his living room,
or whether it's a big media company like you,
Viacom.
WHATEVER! Last time I was on YouTube,
it was like ALL Daily Show and Family Guy
clips!
Ummm...was that, was that 2007?
Uh...maybe...yeah
Well, Since then we've created the world's
most advanced content identification system
which has all but iradicated illegally uploaded
videos fromthe site.
Be that as it may!
YouTube would never have gotten as successful
and gigantic
as it did if it weren't for all the copyrighted
clips.
For example, let me read to you from an email
from one of the founders of YouTube QUOTE
"if you remove the potential copyright infringements
...
site traffic and virality will drop to maybe
20% of what it is."
Even if Steven Chen meant to imply what that
very out of context quote implies,
Viacom has repeatedly put it's own clips on
YouTube,
trying to disguise the fact that they were
uploaded by Viacom.
How are we supposed to know which videos you
want online and which ones you don't!
That's not our concern. Your site was built
on piracy and it is dirty.
If we're so dirty, why did you unsuccessfully
try to buy YouTube?
What!? That...that has nothing to do with
this! This is about our lawsuit. You profited
from our content!
Is it true that Viacom-owned Spike.com routinely
monetizes
videos created by independent video creators
with 30 second pre-rolls without the permission
of the owners?
This is not Spike.com's lawsuit. If those
people want to sue us, they're welcome to.
Oh, OK, I get it now, so it's OK to steal
from someone
if they can't afford a lawyer.
The independent content creators that you're
stealing from.
they're the backbone of YouTube.
Oh come one. Everyone knows that Independent
content is a mere sideshow
when compared to the vast main attraction
of illegal copyrighted content.
Leaving aside that what you're saying is infuriating,
it is also factually innacurate.
But That's not possible. How could YouTube
keep growing
if they're not profiting from pirated clips?
Because our users, indpendent content creators,
and major media companies, all of these people
are uploading
great content to YouTube that people want
to watch.
But they're not watching our content,
and when they are, we can't control the way
that they watch it.
As far as we know, that's not against the
law
But YouTube, you gotta understand.
We can't handle this kind of change.
We're an old media company.
This is the kind of change that means we're
gonna make less money!
Ah...ok...I see, now we have gotten to the
crux of the matter.
Viacom, will you please take your poop out
of our nintendo?
John, I will see you on Monday.